he and maddie from scratch games who are
here to give us an exclusive look at
high on live thank you so much both for
joining us
yeah thank you for having us great to be
here and i'm sure the fans are going to
be super excited about this segment
because you have a tons of gameplay to
show us and i want to see it definitely
but before we jump into that could you
give us like a quick overview of what
high on live means
yeah so high on life is the new game
from justin roiland's studio squanch
games
it takes place it starts out on earth
you're kind of an aimless teenager you
don't really know where you're going
with your life aliens show up they
discover that humans are the best drugs
in the universe and you pair up with a
talking gun that you find to sort of
stop them from ending your species
basically
yeah we're gonna be seeing a bit of
content from the intro tutorial level to
start um you know some fast forward sort
of through here but it's just because we
can only fit so much in this segment
so is that like the typical game from
scratch games you would have
yeah so we kind of we kind of have weird
games like it you know we kind of found
each other we like making weird stuff we
all love comedy we all love weird sci-fi
so
it really is right in our wheelhouse
it's just a leveled up version of things
we've done in the past
amazing so i would say let's just jump
right into the gameplay right because
what people want to see
sounds great
nice house you got
real ritzy way better than my bench oh
wow you really made yourself at home huh
oh there you are who's this weirdo and
why is he setting up a
huge alien computer in our living room
okay
first of all that alien computer is a
very expensive and surprisingly
operational bounty 5000 so uh you're
welcome
i've got just the thing a small time
local gangster by the name of nine torg
she took my favorite knife she's got an
operation out in the slums
maybe a killer and get my knife back
then we'll talk maybe take you out to
glumpies to celebrate all right so we we
just head out to the slums no [ __ ] you
gotta use the bounty 5000 to initiate a
bounty that's what i went through all
the trouble of setting it up for
[Music]
my knife we're looking for the gateway
to the slums i guess looking it
shouldn't be too far listen just follow
the way so i just noticed it's a little
forward like
is that the usual demo is that a cut
group
uh yeah are you talking about fast
forward yeah
so we we're actually showing the full
demo here to pass behind closed doors
but for the purposes of this video we're
just sort of fast forwarding to make
time i understand and the family was at
my house where do i live in there is
that my family yeah yeah so uh early on
in the game kenny gives you the ability
to teleport your entire house to escape
from the cartel so when you teleport
your house your sister's in the house so
you kind of bring her with you
and she's not too happy about that at
first
and the other guy you see in there
that's gene he's a legendary bounty
hunter at least he was a legendary
bounty hunter kind of fell on hard times
and he's homeless and he sees this
opportunity as a way to sort of get your
house so he's like i'll train you if you
let me crash on your couch if you die i
get to keep the house basically and so
he's really in the beginning he's really
hoping you die i understood
yeah the house is sort of your main hub
and then you have the rest of bloom city
for sci content nbc's lots of good stuff
well well
look what we got here fresh meat hey
there fresh meat welcome to the slums
fresh meat
oh boy here we go
kid what's wrong fresh meat you scared
of a little kid you have a little kid
look at me
i'm sorry this kid is this is annoying
what's this all about well honestly he's
just supposed to be annoying basically
so we implemented this
patented squash shove tech basically
where characters get in your face and
push you around it's such a funny little
mechanic and he's one of the first
characters you encounter that's doing
this to you and he's really pressuring
you to shoot him but you don't have to
you can skip it yeah
yeah you meet uh his mom later and he's
actually 30. okay okay so not really
technically you're not killing it and
it's your choice
[Music]
hey you can't pass through here it's
nine towards term jesus enough with
everyone getting in our way we just want
to kill nine torg yeah right you kill
nine torque get lost
so this is exciting we're in our first
combat um yeah who are we fighting in
this kenny's primary ability
yeah so this is the first time you're
really getting to use kenny uh and these
aren't the main enemies you're fighting
these are sort of a lower level set of
goons
and they actually think they're the
strongest enemies in the game but they
find out by the end of this mission that
they're really not and they're just the
ones in the first level it's really
funny it's a really funny sequence and
for kenny you're seeing basically his
primary fire right now this is early in
the game so you're learning how to use
them but throughout the game he'll get
alternate abilities each gun kind of has
three modes one of them is always going
to affect traversal and then on top of
that there's mods for each gun
oh hey you want to see a cool party
trick i used to do amy at those spinny
platforms come on come on give it a shot
it'll be fun
yeah i told you did you see how fun that
was i call it my glob shot it comes out
of my trick hole okay
i'm afraid to ask this question what is
a trick hole is that just a american i'm
sorry i thought that was worldwide
but apparently not uh
so all the guns in the game have three
separate uh abilities so primary
secondary as we mentioned and then
there's an ability fire what you're
seeing here can be used in combat but it
can also be used to open up new
traversal areas and each gun in the game
will sort of open up new areas you can
go back to areas that you were before
and kind of explore find um you know
content collectibles and also get new
npc interactions
yeah we're really trying to push that
light metroidvania feel so the levels
are really dense
i'm sick of this i want to tear through
someone's guts oh i think they're
talking about gene's night [ __ ] gear got
it freak we've had enough of your
[ __ ] yeah it's your fault stepulax
is dead i was in love with him did you
know that i loved him and now his hands
come just the way it should be [ __ ] him
hey guess what i have another secret
trick you can use the power of
negotiation let's try reasoning with
these guys knock on the door tell me how
you please you insufferable
when i'm loose oh
who's there who are you uh hey hello
there friends oh i i think it's the
buyer hey are you the buyer
no i'm just here to do my laundry it's
it's even clean i just i'm a laundry
head can't stop washing stuff over here
this room's off limits everything you
need is in the front get out of here
good luck with your laundry
i mean i have a ton of laundry at home
especially after gamescom but i noticed
there's a lot of dialogue in this thing
can you tell us a little bit about that
yeah so we actually started out kind of
writing out a big dialogue tree our head
writer alec rob was an amazing writer
and kind of makes twine games in his
spare time so we had it down
and then once people got in the booth we
kind of encouraged a little bit of
improv to keep things fresh and funny uh
and then all of that amounts to
basically a huge selection of dialogue
choices and so you just heard him
talking about his ex-lover stephanie
lacks
if you knock on the door before that you
don't even have a chance to give that
answer because you don't know that
information so there's a lot of stuff
like that throughout the game that that
you're kind of opting into without even
knowing
nice job they told us this fire was a
real prankster oh you come on
that was pretty [ __ ] up that joke is
gonna [ __ ] me up
you got him good okay though but enough
of that uh let's show them the product
all right here's the product a genuine
talking knife i gotta be honest with you
he's a real piece of he's extremely
violent he basically only talks about
wanting to kill people in very
disturbing ways [ __ ] you i'm gonna carve
out your cavity gonna make it three
times as big you're it's just gonna drop
right out of there let's see what i'm
talking about oh a perfect that's
exactly what we're looking for yeah yeah
great go ahead feel free to inspect it
try it out see how he feels in your hand
yeah yeah free me let's go let's go
psycho on these
actually you you want to just swing out
the air a bit like far away from us yeah
thanks come on what are you oh
[ __ ] yes thank you pleased to meet you
i'm knifey now use me use me let me [ __ ]
up these clock against oh just a
reminder uh don't do anything crazy when
you're holding the knife just like look
at it see if you like it put it back
yeah thank you
oh [ __ ] yeah
yes more more i need more stabbing
definitely not but let's put a pin in
the whole gene thing how do we get out
of here with my tether ability i'm more
than just a knife you racist i can
tether too look up and latch on
i'm sorry but these lines guys but i
remember i remember nike from the first
trailer and i think for fans he has been
fan favorite from the debut tell me
everything about him yeah so he's by far
my favorite weapon in the game he's
voiced by michael cusack who's awesome
he's so funny
and throughout the game basically he
functions as a knife but he's there to
kind of always pick on you and say funny
stuff he also has this tether ability
which affects traversal through the
level so once you get them you can kind
of go back and some of the levels were
horizontal now they're more vertical and
there's things you can get that you
couldn't get before yeah it's pretty
cool the night the levels really open up
once you get knifey and there's a bunch
of other traversal abilities you can use
in tandem with him and you also uh can't
open chests until you get knifey which
you'll see right here these are lug
boxes uh hopefully we'll be selling
plushies of these plushies and nike
you know always going to have that side
hustle um
so you're actually also getting pretty
close to the end of the level here uh
you're going to fight the uh the boss
nine tour because your first bounty uh
you're gonna be able to use all of your
abilities that you've learned in the
level together so your primary your
secondary you're gonna be tethering
around the air arena and you're also
gonna be deflecting with knife so you
put it all together you find nine torque
[Music]
we're hurting you
that was
you can still use me if you want
i can deflect attacks did you know that
i'm not just all about stabbing well i'm
mostly all about stabbing and tethering
but i can also deflect attacks
matches your toxic personality
[Applause]
incoming laser
laser just for you
i'm taking you with me
stay alive i think she's basically done
for
yeah
so actually we're showing this full
playthrough of what is essentially the
first bounty you get so uh we're showing
that behind closed doors to press um
there should be full videos online of
the whole play through people to check
out uh and we're just so excited to
finally get into people's hands and see
their reactions it's been a real labor
of love for us on the team amazing well
i can say this is a gloomy globby blast
right but when can people get their
hands on the game so december 13th is
going to come out we're really excited
for everybody to check it out working
really hard on it yeah seriously please
check it out like this is really really
a special game to us and we really hope
you guys like it
well mikey maddie i have to say first of
all thank you so much for
sleeping letting us sleep in your game i
really appreciate it and yeah thanks for
having us at the show and enjoy the rest
of gamescom thank you thank you so much
for having us
and